it's safe 95
effective and ready for final approval
that's what pfizer and its german
partner biontech
are saying about their coronavirus
vaccine which they expect to submit to
the fda
for authorization within days in trials
the company said
side effects from the vaccine were mild
boston-based moderna has said
its vaccine still in the final stage of
trials
is also showing over 90 percent
effectiveness
u.s health officials said both could be
rolled out as soon as next month
by the end of december we expect to have
about 40
million doses of these two vaccines
available for distribution
pending fda authorization enough to
vaccinate about 20 million of our most
vulnerable americans and production of
course would continue to ramp up after
that
but president-elect joe biden said on
wednesday that while the vaccine news is
positive
he's being hampered by donald trump's
refusal to acknowledge his election
victory
or allow the biden harris team access to
important information about developments
there's a whole lot of things that are
just we just don't have available to us
which unless it's made available soon
we're going to be behind
by weeks or months being able to put
together the whole
initiative both vaccines use a new
technology called messenger rna
that is being praised for how well it
seems to work
dozens of drug makers and research
groups using a variety of approaches
are racing to develop a covid vaccine
with
astrazeneca and johnson and johnson also
likely to release results of trials this
year
it can't come soon enough with covid
surging around the world
with the united states still the global
hot spot
now averaging around 150 000 cases
and over one thousand deaths a day
rural states are being hit particularly
hard with south dakota and
iowa recording over 50 percent
positivity rates
higher than new york during the peak of
the pandemic in the spring
and while a vaccine appears to be closer
most experts still say
it won't be widely available until early
to the middle of next year gabriel
lozando
al jazeera new york